13 novembre 2015 vers 22h dans le 11e
arrondissement de paris une attaque
terroriste est en cours au bataclan une
équipe de la berri de 12 hommes se rend
sur les lieux et pénètre à l'intérieur
de la salle nous avons rencontré jérôme
le chef de groupe qui dirigeait la
colonne d'assaut ce soir là on découvre
une scène complètement apocalyptique à
savoir on a tous des spots qui sont
dirigés vers le l'entrée du bataclan
donc une lumière blanche aveuglante on a
des centaines de gens devant nous
très difficile pour nous distinguer qui
est mort qui est vivant on a très peu de
bruit aucun coup de feu
des râles
mais c'est tout ce qu'on a et on fait
face à ça on sait on n'est pas sûr à ce
moment avec les terroristes soient
toujours présents et s'ils le sont on
n'a aucune idée de leur localisation
dans un espace de près de 10 mille
mètres carrés
les hommes de la berri établisse un plan
d'action dans un premier temps localiser
ces construire la menace si elle est
encore présente et au plus vite commencé
à évacuer des blessés donc là c'est
notre médecin qui était présent dans la
première colonne qui est le professeur
safran qui commencent à organiser un
triage de victimes
et nous le groupe le premier groupe
avant d'être rejoint par un second
groupe ont commencé à acheminer dans le
bas de la fosse le bas mètre par mètre
pour nettoyer ce qu'on appelle nous
nettoyer la zone c'est à dire s'assurer
qu'il n'y a pas la présence de
terroristes et au fur et à mesure de
cette progression on évacue des blessés
et ont fini à 23h15 par prendre contact
à travers une porte avec un individu qui
nous manque de recul et qui nous
explique très brièvement qui souhaitent
par les négociateurs et qu'il en a sous
son contrôle une quinzaine d'otages y
donc là la menace est circonscrite nous
à ce moment là on sait qu'on a un nombre
d'otages en est terminée on a des
terroristes armés de j d'assaut de type
ak47 et qui sont également porteurs de
gilets explosifs
et chacun sait au sein du groupe au sein
de l'ensemble des opérateurs berry qu'on
va de valeur au contact de ces gens là
donc fatalement que tout ça va se
terminer par un contact rapproché avec
sept types de menaces et pour autant
c'est ça que je voudrais souligner c'est
que personne
n'hésite ne pense à reculer labeyrie
prépare un assaut d'urgence dans le cas
où la situation dégénère mais privilégie
la négociation
cinq appels entre les terroristes et le
négociateur n'aboutissent à rien le feu
vert de l'aso est rapidement donnée à la
colonne on a un groupe face à cette
fameuse porte balcon gauche un groupe
face à la porte qui est située en bas du
balcon droit parce qu'on suppose
également qu'il peut y avoir aussi une
menace de ce côté là on a le raid et le
reste de la berri qui assure la fosse et
le débouché des escaliers qui se trouve
discale et des balcons de part et
d'autre du théâtre donc là on est prêts
on à la situation un peu pas la pire qui
soit on a un couloir
de dizaines de mètres sur 2 mètres de
large entre dix et quinze otages deux
preneurs d'otage équipe et fusils
d'assaut et gilles expo et qui sont
prêts à mourir pour autant on n'a pas
d'autre choix que d'avancer les deux
colonnes de la berri et le raid sont
positionnés et à 00h18 l'assaut est
lancé on se munit d'un port bouclier qui
en tête en tête de colonne qui permet
normalement d'arrêter des cartouches de
bach à 47 et on décide d'y aller mais en
gros bas on progresse sous la protection
se portent bouclier la porte on arrive
on parvient à ouvrir la porte et là on
se retrouve immédiatement sous un déluge
de feu
quasiment à peu près cinq mètres de
distance donc on a nos officiers qui est
gravement touché à la main alors qu'il
se trouve au milieu de colonnes et qui
évacue est sous le feu aussi par deux
autres opérateurs qui se trouve derrière
lui et pour autant personne ne s'arrête
on continue de progresser on les fait
reculer en utilisant des grenades
assourdissantes il faut imaginer qu'à
partir de ce moment là dès que la porte
est ouverte on a des otages qu'ils
viennent vers nous en rampant donc sous
le feu ennemi
nous on est obligé d'extraire tout en
avançant et s'assure également qu'il
s'agit pas de terroristes qui cherche à
s'enfuir donc on est obligé de contrôler
un petit peu les gens qui sortent tout
ça se fait en même temps ils reculent
nous on a un problème avec le porte
bouclier qui basculent vers l'avant
parce que la démarche qui se trouvait là
on peut me connaissaient pas exactement
la configuration de ce couloir qui
bascule pour autant le premier de
colonne lui n'hésite pas à prendre son
arme de poing a plus aucune protection
outre sa protection personnelle et
pourtant continué à avancer et donc
comme ils avancent bien tout le monde
avance derrière toujours un peu comme un
rouleau compresseur si vous voulez
obligeant les terroristes à se réfugier
au fond
au fond du couloir sur la droite où se
trouve un escalier en colimaçon et
quelques instants après
on entend une grosse détonation on sent
du souffle et là on comprend que le
premier à actionner son gilet
d'explosifs dont la chance qu'on a c'est
que la fragmentation c'est à dire ce qui
est destiné à blesser des boulons et
autres par vers un mur au lieu de partir
vers nationaux on aurait eu des blessés
graves notamment aux jambes et aux
membres alors on découvre ce premier
enfin ce qu'il en reste l'autre
terroriste qui a un peu à côté de lui
qui est blessé mais qui cherche à
actionner également songé l'explosif
plus bas dans l'escalier donc là on n'a
d'autre choix que la tra lisez
l'individu afin de préserver notre notre
intégrité physique et celle des otages
environnants le bilan est exceptionnel
seul un blessé grave est à déplorer du
côté de la berri tandis que tous les
otages ont survécu il faut comprendre
que notre opération elle commence à
22h20 et qu'elle finit à une heure du
matin la sauce et le paroxysme de cette
intervention c'est la minute
la pluie peut-être la plus violente la
plus il ya plus de chaos et qui met fin
à la situation mais elle s'inscrit
vraiment dans une opération qui dure
quasiment trois heures on n'est pas là
pour rentrer tels des cow boys et tirer
dans le tas quoi parce que ça
ça n'a pas plu value on est là pour
sauver des gens on a eu pas mal d'unité
étrangères de pays
confrontés aux touristes qui sont venus
également pour débriefer avoir un retour
d'expérience qui avait pu être fait mais
nous on a beaucoup travaillé là-dessus
on a échangé avec bull que l'unité est
effectivement le résultat valide le
procès choisi ce soir là les hommes de
la brigade ont reçu des médailles pour
récompenser leur courage et leur
maîtrise mais étrangement la légion
d'honneur ne leur a même pas été
décernés sauf à la jambe blessée les
otages eux leur voue une reconnaissance
éternelle